coffee on a Tuesday and block for
today I want to talk about the peaceful
protests currently happening in lower
Manhattan called Occupy Wall Street it's
starting to gather some buzz in the
mainstream media which I watched
obsessively and also the rosy eyes of
Michael Moore so you know it's
legitimate
so Occupy Wall Street is a leaderless
protest with a vague set of demands
started by a Canadian activist group
called Adbusters
and aims to model the protests from
Tahrir Square in Egypt last March which
unseated their president Hosni Mubarak
the Tahrir Square protests had a simple
but intense demand Mubarak must resign
the protests in Liberty Park is crowded
with lots of littler less forceful
demands some have come to protest
unemployment some protests the wealth
inequality in this country some of the
wars some the corruption of campaign
finance laws some environmental issues
and some have come just to create a
spectacle
despite their demands presumably
everybody is angry at the same thing the
reckless abandon perpetrated on Wall
Street which caused the subprime
mortgage crisis in 2008 maybe we should
take a minute to understand the
financial crisis one minute so Wall
Street started bundling home loans
together and selling slices of those
loans to investors investors were making
big money so they started pushing the
letter saying we need more loans lenders
were already giving people loans with
good credit so they started lowering
their criteria used to be you needed a
credit score of 620 at a down payment of
20% they'll settle for a 500 credit
score and no money there Joe Schmoe
buyer assumes that if the bank's willing
to lend him money that he must be able
to afford it he buys his dream house the
bank's new securities based on bad
mortgages for risky sort of control
potential fallout they started by an
insurance
if mortgages default the insurance
company pays default swap so the bank's
time potential loss is ensured the risk
moves off their books they invest more
one insurance company took on more swaps
than any other American International
Group why did they do this these
premiums millions
hey how did you figure the housing
market will keep going up up then all of
a sudden the housing prices go down Joe
Schmo buyer bought his dream house at a
teaser rate mortgage now that rate goes
away payments go up he defaults
mortgage-backed securities tanked AIG
has to pay off the swaps all of them at
the same time all over the world they
can't afford it of course so the
government does this
the government under Treasury secretary
Hank Paulson passes the emergency
economic stabilization Act through which
they can purchase Troubled Assets and
inject capital into the banks from a
fund called the Troubled Asset Relief
Program which holds a cool 700 billion
now the quick legislation did prevent a
catastrophe but it didn't stop people
from losing confidence it didn't stop
people from holding on to their money it
didn't stop them from not consuming the
goods and services of this economy so
demand goes down the economy contracts
businesses stopped hiring and three
years later Hank Paulson said this on
Charlie Rose in 2008 their constituents
were angry okay and they had a right to
be angry
they had no part in making this the
constituents that's us they had no part
in making this but did we are we
guiltless they had no part in making
this or had we as consumers pushed and
pushed for years every corporation to
get us the best deals on our goods and
the best returns on our investments are
we complicit in a system which was
driven to do anything to beef up its
stock value and lower its prices on
goods even to the point of selling
bundling and gambling on bad mortgages
so that we could get t-shirts at $28.00
capitalism has strengthened the part of
our brain that our consumers and
investors super capitalism has made us
terrifically a dentist at thinking of
ourselves and practicing being very very
efficient
and adept consumers and investor
don't get me wrong this is not to say
that the Wall Street Titans are
blameless but each of us are made up of
two parts the part that is a consumer
and the part that is a citizen yes
Washington is awash with corporate
lobbyists but what are those lobbyists
actually doing most of those lobbyists
are there in Washington to get a
competitive advantage over their
competitors who are also in Washington
trying to use public policies to get a
competitive advantage over their
competitors the noise level is so high
that the public you and I cannot be
heard at least the citizen in us could
not be heard the consumer and investor
in us is the only voice that is being
heard we are gonna have to be willing to
give up some of the benefits that the
consumer side of ourselves has gotten in
the last few decades and certainly it's
important as citizens that we exercise
our rights like the people in Liberty
Park are doing right now but perhaps
it's more important that as Americans we
exercise our privileges one of our
privileges is to learn and study
anything we want and do it
systematically it's important that we
lead with reason and not emotion if
people are angry and frustrated and
worried about their jobs if they feel
that they are not getting ahead and if
they feel that the dice are loaded
against them that somehow the economy is
is fixed that government and business
are in cahoots that's when you ignite
the kind of social change that could be
very progressive and very reform minded
but also could be very reactionary check
for some cool articles in the doobly-doo
about this thanks for listening and